a snowstorm is one weather phenomenon
you don't want to be surprised by the
same can be said of the yukiona one of
Japan's harshest winter monsters this
icy snow Maiden might steal your heart
or your life she's beautiful and
dangerous the Incarnation of winter
storms in some regions of Japan just
catching a glimpse of this figure will
cause your soul to leave your body other
places give her the trait of motherhood
she will ask you to hold her baby or may
appear accompanied by snow children and
in some region stories she's a vengeful
Spirit actively seeking out those who
wronged her when she was alive
I'm Dr Emily zarka and this is monstrum
many Legends of the yukiona originate in
the tohoku region located in the
mountainous northeastern part of the
country known as one of the coldest
regions of the island the area sees more
snowfall than any other region in Japan
the yukiona is identified by the
blizzards she travels with as beautiful
and pale as the falling snow she may
have black or white hair but it is
always very long her thin tall body can
appear naked but more often it is
wrapped in a blindingly white kimono
Yuki Ona looks like a woman so many
mistake her for a ghost but she isn't
the spirit of a dead person that's
Heroku Yoda author of The Yokai book
Yokai attack the Japanese monster
Survival Guide
she is a Yokai a living personification
of cold and winter
[Music]
but I don't consider yukiona a monster I
see her as an avatar of nature the fact
she's wearing a thing kimono it's such
Condition it's strange but the white
color is odd too of course it symbolizes
Frost and Snow
but traditionally white kimono are also
used as a burial dress for the Dead
it would be very scary to see a woman
dressed in a light white kimono in a
blizzard she can shape-shift into mist
or falling snow making her invisible
against the blizzard she appears
alongside the better to sneak up on her
victims Yuki on this story is a classic
example she tells us to never
underestimate the power of nature and to
be extra cautious when going out in the
winter is especially Into the Wilderness
the yukiona is a kind of winter succubus
type Yokai stories tell of her acts of
Seduction encounters that always end
with her draining the life force of the
men she has relations with more
notoriously however victims die of the
cold either through exposure to the
elements or the woman's icy breath the
snow woman first appears in a collection
of poetry written in the 15th century by
sogi a Zen monk he describes the Yuki
Ona he encountered as tall and beautiful
with very pale skin and white hair his
experience is accompanied by another
tale that would become one of the most
enduring versions of the yukiona the
story of The Woodcutter Legend has it
that while cutting down trees minokichi
and his mentor musaku were caught in a
horrible blizzard unable to cross the
river to return home they seek shelter
in a boat man's Hut later that night
minokichi wakes up freezing noticing the
door the Hut is open he turns to his
mentor and sees a stunningly beautiful
woman standing over him she is
extraordinarily pale skin and is wearing
a snow white kimono she freezes the
mentor with her icy breath then turns
her piercing gaze to minokichi but is
immediately taken by the man's own
Beauty he was unusually handsome she
agrees to let him live on the condition
that he tells no one what happened she
then walks out of the shelter
disappearing into the blizzard a year
later minokichi meets a very beautiful
woman who coincidentally also has very
pale skin the two marry and have 10
children clearly they were into each
other but strangely she never seems to
age remaining as young and beautiful as
she was on their wedding day all was
well until one fateful night seeing his
wife dressed all in white minokichi
absent-mindedly comments that she looks
just like the snow woman he encountered
so many years ago to his surprise and
horror his wife reveals she herself is
the yukiona the wife or not him Furious
she screamed it was me who spared you
that day I should kill you for breaking
your promise she abandons him turning
into a white mist and floating out of a
window never to be seen again this
particular yukiona Legend is the most
popular today largely because of Patrick
hearn's 1904 translation of the story in
his book quaidon this Irish Greek author
published under a Japanese pen name and
claimed to have recorded the story from
a local of the musashino district
however Scholars are careful to point
out that the story is unlikely a direct
translation romance between the yukiona
and the young Lumberjack is
significantly more detailed in his
telling than in other variations
according to his version the Yuki Ona
when disguised as a human woman is named
oyuki her name literally translates to
snow which you think would have been a
clue for The Woodcutter but I digress
the marriage element is common in other
Japanese folk tales as is the husband
breaking a promise to his Supernatural
wife other Traditions across the globe
also use this Trope so it's an
interesting thread to explore these
Supernatural unions seem to reflect an
idealistic fantasy the preter natural
wife is always incredibly attractive as
defined by the ideal beauty standards of
that community and Yuki Ona stories for
instance female beauty is defined by
pale skin long hair and thinness all
characteristics still held in high
regard by popular culture in Japan today
but heroko has another opinion I don't
think Potrero of yukiona's beauty is
about woman at all instead she's a
personification of the beauty of winter
she's like a metaphor reminding us that
the cold months are beautiful but it can
also be deadly another well-known tale
of the yukiona that diverges from the
supernatural marriage Trope appears in a
1705 play titled the five battle doors
of the yukiona penned by chickamatsu
monzeman a noted Kabuki and Puppet
Theater playwright he wrote both
historical and domestic dramas in other
words he wrote about both Legend Dairy
deeds and heroic figures as well as
everyday domestic life the five battle
doors of the yukiona falls somewhere in
between both categories his version
removes the relationship between Yokai
and man in favor of a vengeful ghost
story the drama centers on a man
planning on assassinating a Shogun in
his home during the New Year holiday in
order to do so he must get the shogun's
devoted maid out of the house so he
tells her that her boss is planning to
send an army to fight the Lord Of Her
Lover he instructs her to warn the
others in the household ensuring the
woman that his brother is waiting
outside the garden gate to help her
leave the property in truth This Is A
Lie No One waits for her outside the
still locked Gates and the trapped maid
freezes to death inside the snow-covered
Courtyard but she does not perish
entirely upon her death she transforms
into a snow woman her blue kimono
replaced with a white one then she seeks
revenge against the man who sent her on
the false errand while the dangers of
being stuck outside on a Snowy Evening
are self-explanatory this Yuki on a tail
also warns of the consequences of trying
to change the social order by usurping
the leader of the community in this case
the military after all the would-be
Assassin is punished by the vengeful
snow woman but the fact that the maid
becomes the monster herself also
suggests that all lives are valuable
even if a person is not perceived as a
high-ranking member of society their
lives are no less important while the
dangers of frostbite and hypothermia are
Universal the minor changes in the
yokai's appearance and actions reflect
Regional cultural expectations and
potentially real-life events she's
popular character in folktales so there
are many variations but generally
speaking her attributes don't change
much she's a beautiful woman in a white
kimono in the depth of winter she
reminds us of that but her story also
tells us never to make promises we
cannot keep
so there you have it and I mean hey once
you inspired a Pokemon it's pretty hard
to ignore the pop culture relevance what
was once a metaphor for the dangers of
winter and a warning against false
assurances of trust has become a beloved
but less terrifying character expanding
her reach but also her variation
what was once a metaphor for the dangers
of winter and a warning against false
insurances of trump
Assurance is not insurances holy moly
assurances versus false assurances
false assurances of trust